what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i am going to be reacting to um
little ivy junior featuring frito bang
his
part nuh not partner partner with an a
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos while you're
at it go follow my instagram it's just
probably things but the z
just pearly things change that s to a z
you're going to find my instagram
all right i'm ready to go
[Music]
okay got some weed
okay yeah i've been slanging now since
2012
[Music]
okay so what he's saying he tends to um
dick them quick so he tends to hook up
with the girls
really quickly and be like be on your
way thought
ain't got no love
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he's saying he's just talking
about what he's gonna do to the ops
so in rap music you'll find this theme
where like they want to let the
opposition know
that they're like super hard so to speak
[Music]
okay so he's letting the opposition know
that they messed up
because he's gotten some big guns and
they're not gonna be able to defend
themselves
[Music]
ain't got time to be fighting [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
okay seriously you know that
the opposition is scared of him because
he is not afraid to shoot
he's not oh i got some bread oh and
bread is money so he's saying
i got some bread i got money
i'm not gonna lie this guy looks like
he's 12. he really does
good dance moves looking cool
got got the dance moves in there
you know that was a fun song
main theme of the song really was just
to let his ops know
that he's not afraid of them he's got
some big guns like the whole song was
pretty much
just a threat that's it um so for that
reason
i can't give the song a five it
automatically goes to a three
we don't like threats on the channel um
but i was bopping my head
and stuff so i'll give it a three out of
five let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or you disagree don't forget
to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell while you're at it and
follow my instagram i'll talk to you
guys
next time